you got a little bruise on your knee
after wiping out what the [__] well I
mean last night one hey
chest out
curl then roll
four five six seven eight
[Music]
welcome back to another amazing episode
of the careful boys where we have
subin
so hey you just got in a motorcycle
accident yeah tell us about it
okay so I'm going up Lower Canyon and
then I'm just taking my time usually I
speed up I was taking my time and there
was a car on my ass the whole time and I
was like you know what I'm gonna let
this car pass because at the light I can
still pass him so I'm not even worried
so I get up there in the front and I
could tell before the lights turned
green
the guy behind me
he's doing that you know like trying to
pinch forward so I'm on the bike like oh
I won't take this food like no problem
so why would they do that doesn't you
know it bites way faster yeah but I
don't know I was taking my sweet time I
guess but like it turns green I flirt
I'm going down the hill and I see his I
see his light
just right next to mines because you
know it's one light and you can his life
was just I was just I already knew that
he's on my butt he's Armenian I don't
know only Armenians drive like that
trying to [__] beat a motorcycle I
didn't say that what kind of car did he
have
no what kind of car did he have a Fiat
it was a Lexus orange I have it on video
but I was like I was flooring it I was I
was going and I was going I was like yo
I'm carving real nice right now and I
could but he's still on my butt so I was
kind of terrified so I was like you know
what let me let me let me punch it up
real quick
as soon as I punch it up I see a water
going down the uh the road I was in and
it was like a level it was a crack floor
so I was like oh buddy uh God damn it
instead of craving and I mean cranking
it right right away I just try to go
forward and then slowly turn but soon as
I went for a slow turn the bike just
went right under me oh because the wet
tires yeah it was wet tires bunny
hopping like a [__] regular basket
yeah you didn't try so so I was wearing
shorts that day I can't but dude I went
under and then
my knees oh
and I want these but thankfully for a
full face helmet I went I went helmet
first I went chest and I went did your
T-shirt get ripped up no you're pretty
clean for someone who [__] got were
you wearing like body armor no it was
just this and shorts no Road Rash bro
how did that's it that's it how about
your how good was your chest how come
this didn't get [__] up
is that Hawaii on my chest baby
no Road Rash what the [__] it was crazy
because I never thought this day would
happen like that so I went under it on a
bicycle
it was a motorcycle
[Music]
so I hit the floor but soon as I hit my
face I went I rolled over it and then I
got up and I was like yo what the [__]
just happened so I went to get my bike
the guy who's behind me comes up next
man goes like you stupid [__]
Armenian
I don't know I didn't look at him what
did he sound like to you sounded like a
white dude they say you stupid [__] bro
no he's like you're stupid [__] and
then drove off but that made me so yeah
that made me so mad I got on the bike
tried to look for him yeah I would too
did you find them but I took a picture
of his uh car was it a different car
that called you a stupid [__] no no
same car a different car orange Lexus
[__] idiot same same car
he got his plate
I got the plate though oh the SUV it was
SUV so what if you uh what if a person
watching was able to run that plate and
they on the comments they docked that
guy's address would you go I'm going
[Laughter]
hey you stupid [__] dude
just to say stupid he's still on the
motorcycle at the door boom but I know
him going down Hollywood there so and
I'm gonna always look for that [__]
car when I ride and drive I'ma look for
him damn yeah you shouldn't be just
yelling at people yeah but what if you
to look at the Hollywood sign and it's
not like an actual local and I hope it's
plane crash oh yeah you're right you're
never gonna see them again it blew my
mind because I thought he was gonna at
least come out and ask a girl real buddy
yeah if you see someone crash but we're
not in Hawaii though see that's the
whole culture thing we're in L.A that
really pissed me off but I still thought
that you would have like human decency
they don't give a [__] that's what
happened to me when I think he's hit or
miss when I was riding the [__] I used
to ride this uh one wheel not one with
the solo wheel you know that [__] it
goes super [__] fast like a unicycle
I used to ride that around my
neighborhood and then uh I caught off
this dude and he started [__] with me
on the road and then uh the thing ran
out of battery and I felt like a like
when you fall on those things and they
shut off you tumble like crazy it just
turns off yeah wow and then he came up
next to me and goes what happened you
[__] up and he drove off people are so
annoying so rude yeah it just blew my
mind I was like wow we really live in
this world I feel like in LA when you
see people with car trouble you go
I hope they make it yeah but even that's
nice versus idiot yeah that's another
level dude but then I would probably be
like that too sometimes yeah I'm gonna
be honest I think it's just Karma
because I'm the guy to roll down the
window you [__] dumbass
just drive away if he's slow I'll be
like you [__] snow out oh he has so
many videos of him doing that to people
you take videos of yourself yelling at
me because he got the GoPro on his bike
oh
yeah [__] cell phone being like I
like how you do that to people and
you're like oh the decay of society yeah
when it happens to you hey right here I
got you guys I got you guys this one you
guys are gonna like this one
this one
that's him in the movie theaters
wow
you did a too much wheelie what
he's right back up yeah a little bit of
bite how the [__] do you go through so
many Falls and not break anything and
[__] yourself up all right this is the
last one this one took me out that's too
[__] scary bro what [__] oh oh baby
hey can you send us those videos so we
can play them here oh yeah if that's
okay that's okay with you guys yeah ah
[__] dude that's why that's why it's a
spelling there dude how many times do
you crash in for someone that crashes as
much as you do you're not [__] up
your body's not doesn't look [__] up
he's emotionally hurt you got a little
bruise on your knee after wiping out
what the [__] well I mean last night one
hey
chest out
curl then roll
four five six seven eight
those slip outs though are pretty are
pretty good like this when the bike
slips out from water yeah like I didn't
get have a scratch when that happened to
me yeah it's just like it's like a one
motion thing it goes like this
the thing that [__] you up most is a
high side fall the one where it goes
like that's where you get okay so how
many times have you crashed on your
motorcycle or like hit something where
you've fallen off like unintentionally
because I'm sure you do tricks and [__]
well unintentionally it was probably
just too unintended oh three no Okay so
yesterday in these two
[Laughter]
like I would see him around school
[__] crazy he's doing wheelies on
like like actual streets in between cars
and shitties
this was like
even like on last Sunday we were at the
[__] uh Melrose market and then um me
and my friend were walking along like
just in the market all of a sudden you
just hear a ring and then everyone in
the Market's like who the [__] is that
and it's way outside on Fairfax over the
wall and everyone stopped to turn and
then my buddy goes I think that's stupid
and then he gets to the market like six
hours later he's all yeah that was me
oh I know they're there that's why I did
it I don't want to just do it yeah I
mean like I didn't want to just do it in
the neighborhood I would never do that
when your bike flies like that it still
works yeah because of the K you got
stuck
it flies off [__] hits all these cars
and you're like whoops he just goes oh
man
my shoulder was gone so glad you have a
GoPro dude is that cages like this whoa
you are a lucky [__] dude how
many lives you got you cat you're like
pushing boots and [__] you know what's
funny the the ironic Boots
the irony of this all is that
motorcycles saved his life oh yeah
getting into motorcycling it did it did
how from a life of drugs no no it's just
uh uh I thought I had like I saw
something on my dick one time I don't
know no I don't care I'm serious like
look back what'd you see a birthmark no
it's like a boil yeah I'm gonna tell you
guys right now so growing up I was so my
mentality was like so go go go I was
never into my feelings or deep thought
mindset because I was so young but for
some reason I was just like I'm a shower
let's just see you know let's just clean
down there one time and I saw it when I
was like you never cleaned your dick
before no I did clean my dick man
haha
but I never stand out my own dick for
that long you know what I'm saying so
today's video is brought to you by Lumi
living in Hawaii I've been much more
conscious of my body Organics okay
trying to live that hippie life I'm
starting to learn about all the things
when it's Mass manufactured they do
harmful chemicals and I don't want none
of that on my body too artificial man
but at the same time I want to smell
good you don't want to smell that [__]
so thanks to Lumi they create all these
awesome products that is not harmful to
the body this is the kind of stuff you
can put all over your body on your
eyelids if you got elbows that smell
like [__] anywhere there's a crease
anywhere is a crease put it on because
the doctor that invented this was a ob
gyn and so you know she be smelling down
there all day and she made something to
kill odor added source and last up to 72
hours so in front of me I got whole body
deodorant we got the body wash we got
the stick for the more traditional style
if you like to go like this but their
deodorant is made gentle enough enough
for the [__] so you know it can work
for the body because [__] is very
gentle very very gentle it smells
amazing this right here clean Tangerine
you know what I mean
and if your [__] smells like this oh
[__] you're gonna eat that [__] like
candy I'm gonna get a high five
everywhere you go so the Lumi starter
pack which everything you see here is
perfect for new customers comes with a
solid Stick deodorant the cream tube
deodorant two free products of your
choice like the mini body wash and the
deodorant wipes for after you eat the
[__] and free shipping as a special
offer for listeners new customers get
five dollars off a Lumi starter pack
with code OTR and lumide.com that
equates to over 40 off your starter pack
when you visit Lumi deodorant.com and
use the code OTR so one time I saw it
and I was like I got AIDS yeah yeah I
was just like what is this pimple
no I was like good for you what is this
pimple
so it was the first time I was like okay
let me just look it up that's where I
messed up Google Google the herpes you
might have HIV or Aids or herpes go to a
doctor and I was like down in Chinese
but I never had a health insurance or
anything like that so I was like dude I
can't go too doctor my life is over yeah
so that's when I fell into a depression
State I was like dang I have STDs my
life is done I'm gonna die tomorrow and
you found out that you just had a dirty
dick and a pimple
so I told myself you know what I want to
kill myself this is how I want to go out
because I have STDs so I was like you
know what I'm gonna kill myself like
this is my herpes bro it's like one out
of five
so like you know straight line there was
no other options for me my wife was like
all right guys see this is [__]
embarrassing I'm Asian too this is
whacked I'm gonna die here we go this is
how I'm gonna die why is the Asian a
negative thing because Asians are
supposed to be good smart school not
have STDs yeah but I was just like yo so
you know what I was stuck in a car hell
into my feelings stressing out anxiety
and I see a guy in a motorcycle moving
his head having fun and I was like
that's how I'm gonna go out so I bought
a motorcycle
[__] bro but I was like I'm gonna go
into debt because I'm not gonna be
paying it anyways yeah [__] it which
motorcycle did you get oh CBR 250. Ryan
helped me buy that one oh that's a good
beginner yeah you're helping him with
the suicide I assisted him did you did
you working over here did you know he
had a pimple on his penis I didn't know
that he was going through any of this at
the time until later why didn't you
shoot why did you get 1000 so you could
die fast because I need to learn how to
ride so I can hit a nice streak you know
what I'm saying so I think his life
Works in a straight line straight line
okay see see I had a Honda Rebel you
could have bought mine I sold it hey I
didn't even know you guys yeah it was
nice tell me Brian didn't help but yo so
I got on the motorcycle and I was like
this is it this is what's gonna happen
as soon as I got on the freeway I was
like holy crap this is fun
oh my God this is joyful you know what
I'm gonna live because I love doing this
and I'm gonna keep doing it
so the bike help me thanks bro yeah they
decided not to die never fixed your dick
oh so I went I was like dude I'm a
dumbass why don't I just go to the
hospital so I got on my bike and I went
to the hospital because the bike didn't
save his life yeah wow so I went to the
I went to the hospital and the doctor
was just like let me see your dick
it's not like an alley or something pass
and I was like this is here we go and
you just
bro you just gotta wash your dick make
sure to dry
well what's the pimple from it's just
dirty it was just dirty I mean no it's
just like because I was dancing a lot it
was just sweat oh rubbing so like a
follicle got something you don't be
funny if this pulls a virgin and then
he's all like
this is what I got herpes it's funny
because I remember you when he had asked
me like he called me and he was like yo
you ever get like something on your dick
and like he was asking so seriously like
I'm not used to him being that serious
yeah I was like dog it's probably
nothing yeah and like I was like yeah it
happened to me before like I thought I
had something going on I went to a
doctor and doctor was like that's
nothing and he was like for real for
real that happened to you like he was
like mad serious I was asking because I
don't know I'm about to kill myself for
this damn but I didn't know it was that
far until you were gonna [__] die off
most people do trip the [__] out I
forgot what it was Geo uh could have
sworn she had [__] parasites or some
[__]
yeah it got in her brain oh that [__] or
like [__] or uh or [__] worms or
something she thought something crazy
happened and then so I was like it's
probably not then she goes no I don't
feel right whatever it's with I'm going
to Garfield Medical Center and we go
into the uh emergency room she got a
tapeworm yeah the doctor comes out
she'll go the doctor's like have you
been eating stuff off the floor I'm just
like no he goes have you been eating
your dogs Kaka and then she was like no
he goes then you don't have anything
are you the doctor
and that's when Bart slips him 300 bucks
and the funny thing is the process is so
crazy like you go there you fill out all
this paperwork insurance this like 30
pages then she strips gets in the
[__] gown the kind that you have to
tie and then she goes over here in and
out blood pressure [__] stethoscope
[__] like a whole hour right and
she's like oh my God [__] I know I got
[__] worms or like parasites or some
[__] and the doctor just comes in it's
like have you been eating your dog's
caca she's like no
WebMD [__] you up dude for any medical
thing dude and I was always a guy being
like you're depressed well stop it
don't get depressed loser and then walk
away
let's get out of here so when it was my
time to be like all fertile and scared
and yeah
but I didn't know how to ask people or I
don't know how to express it yeah so I
had no other ways of doing it I was like
you know what I'm gonna ask Ryan yo he
has something on your dick I don't know
how to do it that's why you know dude
that was demanding up for you that's
taking a friend about you you almost
killed yourself for a pimple almost
ain't that crazy dude but remember the
Bible I was like yo this [__] man I
gotta live again you know how you gotta
try to be a police officer you should be
on a bike
yeah you should try to get like into
like one of those bike units or whatever
that'd be tight no that's just doing
wheelies and [__] yeah the the guy said
if you do make it to uh sheriff and if
you don't want to do it just transfer to
CHP oh try to bike all day and they got
[__] an AR in the back yeah that's
pretty cool quiet as [__]
holy [__] this guy's chasing orange
Lexus
I finally got you [__]
it's the wrong one it's like slow
because you can't read the license plate
you're like oh [__] I can't see it
picture's too blurry four or five
I think you'll make it dude
you could learn that was the most
intense lighthearted uh suicide story
I've ever heard yeah yeah yeah but I
don't really talk about it but you know
it was just funny well thanks for
sharing yeah thanks for sharing yeah
because then people that are watching
are probably like man I was gonna
[__] blow my brains out for the same
reason but think for thanks for sub and
sharing that story now they're not gonna
blow their [__] brain watch
motorcycle sales go through the roof to
the Cure depression dude it does feel
crazy though when you ride because like
it was the first time when I saw
because I mean it's so different like
you're going the same speed as a car but
the street
um lines it looks like Star Wars yeah it
goes yeah that's you know like what I'm
talking about like the yeah the the when
there's like the it looks like Star Wars
lights that are just like like you're
going into [__] hyper speed yeah but
you're only going like 40 miles per hour
it's because you maybe you normally
don't see that much of the road oh yeah
when I write a a bicycle on the road I'm
like this is too fast this [__] it's
not the same sorry sir I know so can you
imagine a motorcycle yeah yeah a
motorcycle I'd be like I can only do 30
miles an hour you know what I remember
your scooter I was so scared yeah he was
a little scared I brought the scooter
here one day and he was like I think I'm
good
you know what I like about what you did
though I feel like that's kind of like
the theory of like if you're depressed
that just means your life's not fun
enough so do more fun [__] like that's
the only way it's gonna get your life
out of a bad place pulling yourself out
of it yeah if you're all sad and [__] go
do the next fun thing that's what yeah
that's true I've never really seen
anyone depressed on a zip line
right
I never seen anyone just sad hanging
down like this what about those those
big people that get stuck halfway
well continue to be depressed because
now you know what you got to work on
your way yeah but actually when you're
fat you go faster it's more fun so just
scared
but yeah I like that the formula is like
if you're sad do something happy you're
like oh [__] yeah I feel like they're
just stuck in up or do new [__] new [__]
the new [__] exactly you're stuck in a
pocket once you step out of it one time
dude it could break that Circle I think
so I've never seen a depressed person on
a bumper car
yeah yeah I think a bumper car is a
pretty good cure for depression
um bumper cars Ziploc where this is
going yeah we're out what else dude we
can make a company laser tag bumper cars
with the Taliban we cure depression yeah
instead of going to a therapist we
literally have you come in act like
remember therapist but we just take you
on fun [__] to do yeah wasn't this like
the script for Patch Adams yeah
but it's not depression it was like fun
yeah there was like they're like
terminally ill yeah oh [__] I don't know
about that one but laughter is the best
medicine though yeah I think so it's
time to make people laugh and then the
person that played Patch Adams is the
ultimate sad person yeah the irony yeah
but also he should have zip lined more
Robin Williams get a motorcycle he owned
pugs dude he did you own pugs yeah he
must love pugs not a fun fact for you or
is that like also is it not a fun fact
for you so the pugs weren't enough for
him to be happy well he only had one
that's the problem you gotta have two
we're gonna have at least two bro
okay